في ساحه متحف هونداي باريسي العريق قدم
طارق كريستيان جور الازياء مجموعه جديده
في الخياطه الراقيه والاوديو لربيع وصيف
هذا العام مجموعه مستوحاه من تاريخ
جوزيفين بكار نضالي فهي كانت مغنيه وراقصه
امريكيه من اصل افريقي انتقلت من الولايات
المتحده في منتصف عشرينيات القرن الماضي
الى باريس العصريه التي كانت وجهه حالمه
للفنانين والكتاب ومصمم الازياء التي كانت
تجسد عصريه تلك السنوات حضرت اوروبا في
مرحله ما بعد الحرب وقدمت عروض على مسرح
تراند وفي قاعه كارليج اويل في نيويورك
وفي قاعه كارناجيل في نيويورك
الفرنسيه على غرار ابتكاري جيور
[موسيقى]
من السعوديه
ده الموسم قطع حيكه من الحرير والمخمل
بتاثير المتجعد وايقاع المتسامل مضيفا على
القماش لمسه نابضه بالحيويه اما التطريز
فاتسم بطابع مرهف تنتشر الازرار الفضيه
والترتر على التصاميم كما رافقت الشراريب
الفضيه والذهبيه بعد قطع المجموعه
والبدلات والمعاطف بالاقمشه الرجاليه التي
لا طالما احبها الراحل كريستيان ديور
شاركت العرض وتميزت القطع والسفليه
للاطلالات بطولا يصل الى فوق الكاحل العين
كاشفه عن احذيه عاليه الكعب بن عالم جريء
[موسيقى]
سبونج بوب
التي تعبر عنهما هذه المجموعه